draw the line people make mistakes all
the time they start companies they think
they can manage they have grand and gold
visions that were little too grandiose
this is all perfectly fine it's what
being an entrepreneur or creative or
even a business executive is all about
we take risks we mess up the problem is
that when we get our identity tied up in
our work we worry that any kind of
failure will then say something bad
about us as a person it's a fear of
taking responsibility of admitting that
we might have messed up it's the sub
cost fallacy and so we throw good money
and good life after bad and end up
making everything so much worse ego
kills what we love sometimes it comes
close to killing us to act with
fortitude and honor wrote Alexander
Hamilton to a distraught friend and
serious financial and legal trouble with
own making if you cannot reasonably hope
for a favorable extrication do not
plunge deeper have the courage to make a
full stop history is full of people who
suffered abject humiliation yet
recovered to have long and impressive
career politicians who lost elections or
lost officers due to indiscretion but
came back to lead after time had passed
actors whose movies bomb authors who got
writer's block celebrities who made gas
parents who made mistakes entrepreneurs
the faltering company executives who got
fired athletes who were cut people who
live too well at the top of the market
all these folks felt the hard edge of
failure just like we have when we lose
we have a choice are you going to make
this a lose-lose situation for ourselves
with everyone involved or will it be a
lose and then a win because you will
lose them life it's the fact a doctor
has to call the time of death at some
point they just do at any given time in
the circle of life we may be aspiring 16
or failing with wisdom we understand
that these positions are transitory not
statements about your value of the human
being when success begins to slip from
your fingers for whatever reason they
respond isn't a grip and floss so hard
that you break things it's to understand
that you must work yourself back to the
aspirational face you must get back to
first principles and best practices he
and he fears death will never do
anything worthy of a living man Seneca
one said you must be strong enough to
maintain your dignity and self-respect
because the only real failure is been
abandoning your principal killing what
you love because you can't bear it apart
from it is selfish and stupid if your
reputation can absorb a few blows it
wasn't worth anything in the first place
failure sucks deal with it with dignity
and self-respect it can ruin your life
only if it ruins your character Marcus
Aurelius draw the line
you